stories have the power to move us they
can spur us to do the impossible
good stories give us a framework for how
to look at life and in business the most
influential stories are based on
actionable data in this nanodegree
program will be weaving data into
stories and visuals using various tools
and techniques stories are a powerful
way to draw on the audience make sense
of data and help businesses make better
decisions whether you have a data
background and you want to maximize the
impact of your analyses or a business
background and want to persuade others
to make more data-driven decisions this
program will help you combine the power
of data analysis and storytelling to
make you a more effective and persuasive
communicator throughout the program
you'll build projects where you showcase
all the data storytelling skills you've
been learning your combined interactive
storytelling with data animation across
two platforms tableau and flourish
you'll not only learn how to create
stories using tableau but also how to
incorporate advanced animations and
narration into your stories in Rome and
unleash your inner storyteller
[Music]
you